جاهز
بحيث يجب أن تأتي البطن في
فترة الحمل في وقت الجائحة ، يأتي
مع سؤال كبير حول
ما إذا كنت ستحصل على اللقاح
[موسيقى] ،
والبقاء مستيقظًا في الليل والبحث
عنه ، أصبح الأمر أشبه إلى حد ما
بهوس يقال لدقيقة واحدة بعدم تناوله
في اللحظة التالية ، هل لديك كان الأمر
مربكًا إلى حد ما ،
استمر تغيير
المسؤولين البريطانيين في نصح
الأمهات الحوامل أولاً بعدم التطعيم ،
ولكن منذ يوليو حثه بشدة
في الولايات المتحدة ، لا يوصي مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC)
به بشكل مباشر للحوامل ولكنه يقول
إنهم مؤهلون بينما يتقدم اثنان
تقول مجموعات التوليد أنه
يجب
تحصين الأمهات الحوامل غير
القادرين
على العثور
على إجابات واضحة.  بالنسبة لـ covid19
في ذلك الوقت ،
اعتقدت أنني سأموت ، لكن كان من
المرعب أن أعلم أنني مصابة بهذه
العدوى التي تنتقل عبر بلدي  لقد
أصاب أحدًا مثل أمي وطفلها بالمرض ، حيث
أجرى الأطباء عملية قيصرية طارئة
أخذتها إلى nicu
ولم أر طفلي لمدة يومين
لأنني غطيت
كلاهما الآن في المنزل سعيدًا وصحيًا ،
مرحبًا ،
أنا فقط أريد حقًا  القصة لتكون
نصيحة إذا كنت تفكر في الحصول
على اللقاح ، احصل عليه
98 من الأمهات الحوامل
المقبولات في المستشفى مع covid19 في إنجلترا نظرًا لأنه
ربما لم يتم تلقيحها ، فإن
الميزان لصالح فوائد
التطعيم مقابل مخاطر
العدوى  لم تشمل تجارب اللقاح الأولية
النساء الحوامل ،
لكن الخبراء يشيرون إلى ما يقرب من 200000
حامل تم تلقيحهم بأمان الآن في
جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة
في الحديقة ، نسأل عما إذا كان
الدليل الواقعي كافٍ ارفع يدك
إذا حصلت على اللقاح من
أجل  لا توجد بيانات كافية هناك
شخصيًا مما قمت بالبحث عنه
لتجعلني أشعر بالراحة في الحصول عليه ،
لقد شعرت بمزيد من الراحة والأمان
مع العلم أن لدي بعض الحماية أكثر من
عدم وجود حماية
لا تزال غالبية الحوامل في الولايات
المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة غير محصنة ، ولا يزال العديد منهم
ينتظرون إجابات.